masahiro tanaka on the hill
in the first of three against tampa so
meadows
is ready tanaka is ready and let's do it
swing and a miss tanaka
strikes out meadows one away here in the
first so here is lao hitting 338 as an
eight-game hitting streak fly ball
center field deep going back hicks he's
on the track he'll make the play in dead
center in front of the wall for the
second out and now yandy diaz fly ball
right field coming on is frazier on the
run toward the line he makes the play so
masahiro has a one two three blake snell
always says
he loves pitching against the yankees
it was the place where he made his major
league debut back in april of 2016. now
here is a very surprising leadoff man
and luke voight and voight does what
leadoff batters are supposed to do he
walked
to start off the first and here is
urshela
and lifts the fastball into right
and lau is there to make the catch now
one down here is hicks
in the dirt perez can't find it and
hicks
watches as voigt goes into second luke
voigt feels like a leadoff hitter now
felt like he stole second base he except
two cracks at a run
and the breaking ball lifted into
short center coming in is kiermeier
two gone and voight remains at second
base two out and a runner at second
upstairs gleber torres swinging a fly
ball towards right field pushing loud
back to the edge of the warning track
onto it now he catches it and retires
this side now here's joey wendell he's
playing second and lau is playing the
outfield swinging a ground ball past the
diving first baseman boyd he might have
knocked it over into foul ground it's a
fair ball wendell around first he digs
for second and he is in the raise first
hit of the game with one out enough
comes willy adams line into center field
right there is hicks and they're going
to turn this into a double play
wendell just took off read that
incorrectly and a double play to end the
inning now watch the third base coach
rodney laras he's waving him home
oh maybe you better not and it scored
eight four six for the double play one
away here's kevin kiermann the lefty
hitting center fielder and now tanaka
with that leg whip and pitch and here's
a swing and a rocket down the right
field line it's fair and into the corner
it goes frazier over to go try and dig
it out he has trouble with it kirimeyer
racing the second he turns on the
afterburners he's on his way to third
and he's going to get there sliding head
first with a triple and so kermeyer
stands at third with one out and the
rays looking to take an early lead here
with michael perez up the plate blind to
the center field that's a basic
kiermeier can walk home michael perez
with the rbi single and he gives the
raise a one-nothing lead here in the
third that's three straight hits for the
raise against tanaka there's two on with
one out and brandon lau coming up now
can you pounce a little bit remember lao
hit one to the base of the wall and
center his first time up he seems to be
squaring everything up it's time to have
more than just one time to be greedy
branded named the
american league player of the week
yesterday by major league baseball for
hitting 448 with four doubles four
homers and ten runs batted in in the
seven games last week here's a swing and
a high fly ball to center picks going
back turns around to the wall it's gone
brandon lowe with a three run home run
his eighth home run of the season and
the rays have opened up a four nothing
lead in the bronx well he just missed
the first one he didn't miss this one at
all and the race has second and third
with two outs and michael perez coming
up the other thing you gotta be aware of
right now is the fact that the ball does
get away from gary sanchez a little bit
so the rays have to be ready at third
base for that runs inside and it's boxed
by sanchez back to the screen it goes
adamus comes home and scores and the
rays take a five-nothing lead you called
it gotta be aware he knew it was coming
he just missed it so let's see if blake
can put together another shutdown inning
well two down here's gary sanchez that
pitch is hit in the air to deep left
center it is high it is far it is gone
the fifth home run sanchez
has hit off blake snell the yankees are
on the board
they trail 5-1 oh that gary is scary
tanaka is still out there and he faces
the top of the order starting with
meadows swinging a drive high in the air
to straight away center with hicks
turning and looking at the wall and it's
gone homer on the rays get the run right
back on an austin meadows homer and the
rays have a six to one lead in the bronx
oh and they're taking out tanaka the
rays knock him out
one better into the fifth inning mark
the date and time the rays finally get
to masahiro tanaka and they do it in a
big way so runner at first charles
snyder is going to come out and talk
things over with blake to make sure that
they're on the same wavelength as far as
luke boyd is concerned third time
through the order that one's driven deep
to left field going back as meadows he's
on the track he's at the wall
sia a two run home run for boyd the lead
off man with power
three home runs in the last two games
and it's 6-3 tampa bay the bases are
full of yankees and this is diego just
making a mess of things and here's luke
voight strike
recall oh my it took a little while for
chad fairchild to ring him up but he
finally did
and boyd is punched out for the second
out here on the seventh and now there's
two outs and there's geo urchella a
dangerous dangerous fitter swinging the
ground ball toward third fielded by
yoshi his long throw is in time and
diego gets out of it diego loaded him up
and then he gets out of it jazz row is
on the pitch and so to be up the road to
try to get these final three outs with a
three-run cushion to earn the save and
the yankees are down to their final out
high fly ball right center field
playable keemeyer back in front of the
warning track he catches it and the rays
have won in the bronx they deal the
yankees their first home loss
in the 2020 season